this Sunday of Super Bowl 51 and as your
friends with broken kneecaps will tell
you you can place bets on absolutely
everything way more than just whether or
not Bill Belichick will masturbate
through with hoodie pocket some of the
real profits you can make actually make
unsuitable Sunday include 25 to 1 odds
someone catches fire during the Lady
Gaga halftime show and 45 to 1 odds the
fan throws a dildo on the field and if
you're wondering how a fan would get
access to a dildo let me repeat Lady
gaga halftime show so comedians the
possibilities are endless please come up
with as many more prop bets for the
Super Bowl as you can in 60 seconds and
begin
Koechner 50 to 1 odds that Chris
Hardwick spends Super Bowl Sunday
watching reruns of Star Trek next
generation yeah like a pro right no no
could be could be dr. hill you don't
know what strange a thing Aisling a
ten-to-one odds that the russians
already know who won the Super Bowl
yeah 1 to 1 odds that Trump will tweet
that his crowds were bigger yeah boy
that's a fifty to one odds on
record-breaking attendance at a a
methinks on Super Bowl Monday yeah fine
hi wonder one odds that a guy wearing a
make America great again hat local in
his pants when he sees the word Patriot
all right boy
[Applause]